And now to you, Scoutmaster.
So here we are, We're out in the woods, We're getting ready to take a hike.
And I talked to the senior patrol leader. I say,
Listen, have you reviewed hike safety and everything with everybody?
Yes, Yes, sir, I have. He says:
Have you talked about the buddy? Yes, We've talked about the buddy system.
I said: What are you going to do if you discover one of the boys has gotten separated from the group?
And he said: Well, you know, we will stop and we'll retrace our stops,
We'll kind of fan out, We'll be able to find them.
So what are you going to do if one of the adults gets separated from the group?
He says: Well, that really depends on who it is.
Smart boy, that senior patrol leader.
This is podcast number 93.
Oh
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look and see who's been in touch over the past week.
We heard from Mike Manzer via Facebook.
He said I enjoyed the panel discussion in podcast number 92.
And I hope that you do it often.
The discussion about the new leader training modules was especially timely.
I've used the others that were discussed and found that each one needed some improvement.
I look forward to reading through the new youth leadership training module
and hopefully adopting it with success.
Mike, I'm glad you enjoyed the discussion.
I'm glad it was useful and timely.
One of the things we did discuss was a new troop leadership training syllabus
that the BSA has recently published.
We are going to have Scoutmaster panel discussions on a regular basis-
I would say about once a month- on the podcast here
And you can participate in those by getting in touch
and sending me a question or a comment or a topic suggestion
And your question may be selected to participate during the recording of that podcast via telephone.
We'll call you up and you can ask your question
and you can have a little exchange with the Scoutmaster panel.
We did that last time and I think we found that pretty useful
and we really enjoyed doing it again.
So you can be in touch by emailing me at scoutmastercg at Verizonnet
and you can also get in touch through the contact form at scoutmastercgcom.
I also heard from my friend Scout of Richard up in Canada.
Richard and I exchanged some ideas and some advice via email back in the spring
about moving his troop towards more youth leadership.
He sent me a progress report last week,
He said shortly after the discussion we had.
I took the advice you provided me back to my fellow adult leaders
and we laid out an approach I thought we should take.
It was generally well received by them,
although I do recall there were a few moments of convincing and explanation,
But in the end we all got on the same page.
Then we took these things and shared them with our youth leaders
And then, if we fast forward a few months,
all the adults have attempted to be as consistent as possible
with support and advice when we are asked by the youth.
And although we're moving a little bit slowly with plans-
and that might be an adult perspective, I agree, Richard-
Most of the time it's an adult perspective.
Scouts tend to move a little slowly with planning.
I do think that it is gradually moving forward
towards the youth leadership goal we laid out in the spring.
There doesn't seem to be any real shortcuts here at all.
It just has to happen when it happens.
Your continued support and advice is always appreciated
And I sincerely thank you for your wealth of resources
through the blog and the podcast.
Well, Richard, I'm really happy to hear from you.
I'm glad that the advice that we shared with you
back in the spring is now bearing some fruit,
And your email reminds me that scouting is really a process.
It's a process where we're always traveling,
We're always moving forward,
but we're never really reaching a goal.
It's a landmark that we're going to get to
and we're going to say, okay, hey, we're done,
We've accomplished everything that we needed to accomplish.
Nope, because scouts are different,
The way that they look at the world is different,
but the scouting program and the genius behind it
meets them where they are and lets them learn skills
to become good, productive, happy people
and to contribute to their communities and the world.
And we're going to talk a little bit more about that
in Scout Master Ship in seven minutes or less.
And then we do have an email question to answer
and that'll take care of this week's podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
In seven minutes or less.
You know, one of my all-time favorite scouts online
is Andy over at Ask Andy,
And if you haven't visited there,
you go to the United States Scouting Service Project website,
which, if you're listening to this,
you've probably already been there.
So go over and look at Ask Andy on that website.
It's a kind of an advice column for scouts
and it is just great.
And I saw something in answer to a question
in his latest column and here's an excerpt from it.
I wanted to include it here
because I think this has said something
that I kind of try and say all the time,
but Andy has said it so well.
I don't really think I can improve on it
As this: our charge as volunteers in the movement
is to help create tomorrow's productive,
responsible, happy citizens.
We can't do that if we don't keep our doors in our arms
open to these young men,
understanding that the ultimate volunteer isn't us,
it's the scout himself.
If he gets sick and tired of our nagging him
instead of positive reinforcement of good habits,
or dinging him when it comes to rank advancement,
even when he's proven he can knock off
the skill set required without breaking his sweat,
then he's going to walk,
And that's the very last thing we want to have happen,
because then we can no longer instill in him
the ideals and values of the movement.
Yes, we're a movement and not an activity.
So here's my single guideline:
Look only at the individual scout,
See only the individual,
Understand only the individual,
Each, one by one and one at a time.
Each and every young man who crosses the doorstep
of scouting is unique
and he lives in a world and an environment
unique to him and him alone.
There is no other like him in the world
than we dare not apply an arbitrary measure
in this one particular dimension that we call active.
Now, obviously, Andy was answering a very specific question
about, you know, this age-old question
of how do we determine if a scout is active or not.
But I think in that statement he has encapsulated
the most productive, the happiest
and the most stress-free approach to scouting,
And that is that scouting is a highly individualized thing
And as scout leaders it is our job
to make sure that the scouting program
affects that individual scout
And that's it. That is it.
Everything else is for the birds.
One of the fellows who runs the US Scouting Service project.
he says if it's not for the boys, it's for the birds,
And I absolutely agree.
When we're focused on the individual needs
of each individual scout,
everything begins to fall into place.
If you want to back that up even more,
go over to PTC Media
and listen to the last SMM podcast by Scout Master Jerry,
in which he recorded a session. he did
a training session, he did about Scout Master Conferences,
And Jerry talks about understanding the needs
the personality and the way that scouting impacts
an individual scout,
And he does it very, very well.
I encourage you to go over and listen to that.
I can't present a program that impacts an individual scout,
wherever he is, however he comes to us,
whatever his environment is,
whatever he has to deal with outside of scouting,
then we're failing what I consider to be
the most central object of our work as scout leaders.
If you're looking for the unified theory of scouting,
that's got to be it
And I really appreciate it.
I appreciate Andy writing as he does
and that particular statement that I just read,
And I appreciate Scout Master Jerry over at the SMM podcast
putting that so clearly in the recent podcast
he did about Scout Master Conferences.
I encourage you to look at both of them
and I sincerely hope that it all helps you refocus
your efforts on those individual scouts.
Hi, this is Dr Paul Auerbach
and you are listening to Clark Green
on the Scout Master podcast.
Find me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Well, I got this question from Mike Beck,
who is a Scout Master from Troop 61 in Brandon, Florida.
I have a scout who is not on the Patrol Leaders Council
but he's interested in performing a leadership project
in order to make Star.
Mike's referring to a common statement that you'll find
in the Star or Life rank requirements
that talks about a Scout Master assigned leadership project
to help the troop.
Mike goes on to say: do you have any suggestions?
Whatever it is, I'd like it to be at least two things.
I'd like it to require regular activity,
so it's something that wouldn't be just completed in two weeks
around a single camp out,
and that it would cause the scout to consciously think
about serving the needs of others in his troop.
So I got back in touch with Mike
and I would start the process of identifying
what that Scout Master assigned leadership project
is going to look like by sitting down with a scout
and asking him what ideas he has.
You know how about the Senior Patrol Leader?
Is the Senior Patrol Leader need somebody to do a specific thing,
Not necessarily just like a limited task,
but does he need somebody to occupy a role
or a function for a period of time
that's going to help him with his job in the troop?
Scout Master assigned leadership projects
are very loosely defined, and necessarily so,
because what it does is. it gives you the opportunity
as a Scout Master and the scout the opportunity as a leader
to find different ways- that might be slightly outside
the definitions of positions of responsibility in scouting-
to help his fellow Scouts.
I don't think that this has to be one thing.
It could be several things.
What's important is that you and the Scout agree
on a set of expectations.
I have a Scout right now who was a Patrol Leader.
He's a Star Scout.
Most of the positions of responsibility
within the Patrol Leaders Council
that aren't directly patrol related are occupied.
I have an instructor,
We have a Senior Patrol Leader,
Assistant Senior Patrol Leader, Scribe and Quartermaster.
This Scout came to me and said:
what leadership position can I have?
He and I talked for a while
and I described what in basketball
I think is called a Pivot Man.
I'm not a big basketball expert,
but I used it just to illustrate.
you know, a Pivot Man in basketball
is somebody who can play just about any position,
can get in there and help the team out
whenever he's needed.
I said: you know, you can be our Pivot Man
in the troop.
There'll be plenty of opportunities for you
to step in and to help out
in a leadership capacity
with many different things
And you and I'll just keep an eye on it
And our expectations will be
that when we're ready to evaluate
how well you have done
that, we will have had an ongoing discussion
about the different tasks that you've undertaken.
So you need to be conscious
whenever you do
something to help the troop out.
Just kind of keep it in mind.
You might even write it down.
It's a scout-master conference.
That's what we'll be talking about
And I'm going to have an ongoing dialogue
with this scout
about how he's doing and how he's taking advantage of things.
You know there'll be a time
when the quartermaster is going to need a hand,
Not just arranging things and putting things away,
but he's going to need a hand
working with the different patrols
and making sure they get the stuff that they need.
There's going to be times when the scribe is going to need a hand,
when the senior patrol leader is going to need a hand,
when the assistant senior patrol leader
is going to need a hand.
We were off on a backpacking trip this weekend
and we were shy- a patrol leader or two
So this guy can go in
and help mentor a younger scout
in leading his patrol through a camp out.
There's just dozens and dozens
of ways to approach this,
And I think that we get frustrated sometimes
as scout leaders because we think
you know well, the boy really needs a patch.
But using the scout-master assigned leadership project
is a great way
to help a guy fulfill that requirement
in the next rank.
Now you and I both know
that wearing a patch does not make you a leader.
That's right.
Occupying a position does not make you a leader.
What makes you a leader is what you actually do.
So I am very happy
that this is built into
scouting And it's wonderfully flexible
and individualized.
And that seems to be the theme of the podcast today
is treating scouts as individuals
and dealing with their individual wants, needs,
desires and talents.
We've used it many times very effectively
in helping develop
a young man's leadership skills
and helping him find different ways
to help his fellow scouts.
So, Mike, I hope that's helpful to you.
I'd like to know how you handled the situation
And if you've ever used the
scout-master assigned leadership project
or have some ideas about it,
let me know so I can share it with everybody else.
Well, thank you for listening.
If you haven't touched with us
first, you can go to
scoutmastercgcom.
That's the home of the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast,
And there's a number of resources there
that you might find useful.
You can subscribe to the scoutmaster podcast on iTunes
and, when you do, feel free to leave a comment
or review or a rating.
If you have a smartphone
or other kind of mobile device like that,
you can access the podcast on that mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio.
It's a free app. You can put it on your mobile device-
smartphone, iPad, whatever-
And you can get details about that
at Stitchercom.
So that's Stitcher Smart Radio.
You can get the details about that
at Stitchercom.
You can also call us and leave a voicemail
comment or question at
484-734-0002..
You can experience
scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
That's right. you can follow us at
scoutmasterblog on Facebook.
You can tweet scoutmastercg on Twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle,
Go and search for
scoutmastercg on Google+.
If all else fails,
hey, we have email, right,
We have questions
and you're wild ideas at
scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
That's scoutmastercg
I need to remind you that the
scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
It's only me folks.
I've got my hands on a microphone
and a computer and now
you're listening in.
We just want to help you out
and maybe have a little bit of fun.
Before we go, let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Well, thank you, sir,
Until next time.
Thank you.